[Music]
with an unusually glum start to the day
and the New York Stock Exchange where it
seen the Bell was tolling for stock
prices this was the scene on the big
board within just a few seconds the Dow
down a whopping nine point seven one
percent and it kept on plunging trading
on the S&P 500 was suspended after a
nine percent fall Germany's benchmark
dax index fell more than 10% shares in
the German blue chip Index fell under
the 9,000 point mark for the first time
since 2016 earlier Asian markets also
continued to draw up tokyo's Nikkei was
down
despite emergency monetary action by the
Bank of Japan a Hong Kong and Shanghai
were also trading lower that after
Chinese authorities released data
showing retail sales down more than 20%
and industrial output down by 13.5
percent among the hardest hit sectors
the tourism and travel industries
countrywide lockdowns travel and
hospitality restrictions are already
hurting the sector now German Travel
operator - he says it's suspending the
bulk of its operations while air
carriers are temporarily laying off
staff meanwhile an airline consulting
firm is warning that most airlines
worldwide could be bankrupt by the end
of May the warning comes as air carriers
cut jobs and seek government aid to make
up for falling ticket sales and
cancellations due to the Cova 19
pandemic all right we have our business
correspondents following this story for
us
Aaron Tilton is with us here in our
studio when Chelsea Delaney is over at
the Frankfurt Stock Exchange she'll say
I want to start with you we've heard
there are huge problems for the travel
and tourism sector and it doesn't really
seem like investors are taking that this
well today no it's been really a
bloodbath for the for the airline
industry and its shares in particular
one of the biggest losers we're seeing
here in Frankfurt on the Dax is
Lufthansa which is down about 12 to 13
percent today so this is really coming
after also a lot of volatility over the
past several weeks
number of Airlines Lufthansa air
france-klm British Airways all of them
have lost about half of their market
value over the past several weeks as the
travel restrictions have started to
increase and airlines are doing all that
they can right now to really sort of
offset these these impacts they're
cutting staff they're cutting routes but
it is becoming increasingly likely that
they're going to run out of cash at some
point soon okay so it's a dramatic
situation for airlines Erin coming to
you we've heard that germany's tui is
now suspending much of its operations
how bad do things look for the tourism
industry well I'm not gonna sugarcoat it
they look bad you really have to to look
at this in the broad perspective I mean
this is a perfect storm for the tourism
industry of course tourism is based on
the idea of free travel amongst
countries and we're seeing one travel
restriction after the other crop up
roads being closed airports being closed
and why don't we just stay with the
airline industry I mean these are just
some of them the some of the headlines
we've been getting in here in the last
couple hours British Airways says it's
closing 75% of its routes in the coming
weeks
Air France also the same thing canceling
70 to 90% of its routes
easyJet same thing 75 percent of routes
will be closed in April in May and in
the United States American Airlines also
says that they're closing on their
international capacity by 75% I mean
that's a huge blow to um the airlines
and one that it's going to be very very
difficult for them to recover from I
mean that's why just as Chelsea were
saying there we're seeing them approach
government saying that they're gonna
bail out some type of financial
assistance and then also going to the
unions and saying look you know they
can't keep that entire staff on if
they're to actually survive this this
pandemic crisis that we're seeing right
now we were initially talking about
short-term disruptions are these
businesses really prepared for a
long-term disruption well that really is
the big question and you know with the
airline's I wouldn't be worried about it
that much because just I mean they're
they're huge industry and just as we saw
in the financial crisis they're the type
of industry that governments like to get
involved with and do like to bail out
and make sure that they survive because
they employ so many people what I would
really be concerned with are some of the
secondary and tertiary companies
involved in tourism so I'm talking about
things like hotels like restaurants like
small mom-and-pop shops and mom-and-pop
shop or houses that are dependent upon
tourist dollars to stay open
I mean
and that level the margins are so thin
they really can't afford to stay closed
and each day that we remain that we they
remain closed it increases the
probability that they won't be able to
open up their doors and then there's
also the fact of their employees a lot
of them are like seasonal employees
there's their shift workers they're
freelancers they don't really have you
know the savings that they need to be
able to really get through a long term
break like this and that could have a
huge knock-on effect long terms in terms
of the economy once we're through this
she'll see what does things look like
they're in Frankfort what our traders
saying about the long-term effects of
this pandemic well this is obviously in
the next several months going to have a
significant impact on economic growth if
we see economies grind to a halt like
they did in China like they're gonna
edilene right now that will really
impact the entire economy in the long
term investors economists do see the
economy rebounding and the next several
months and by 2021 for example but in I
think this is also raising a lot of
questions about the future of
globalization is this going to have
people sort of coming back and coming
back home but all of that still up in
the air right now all right
our business team here Chelsea Delaney
in Frankfort and Aaron Chilton with us
here in our studio thank you both very
much thank you the German decision to
close its borders it already ruffled
some feathers here in Europe let's go to
DW correspondent Gareth mattis standing
by in Brussels hi Garrick French
president demand over my call he is not
happy with Germany's border control
measures tell us more about that that's
right the French president after having
a phone conversation with German
Chancellor Angela Merkel condemned these
measures saying that this is not the
right way to act in order to stop this
virus to make a mutual effort to stop
this virus and it was reiterated in the
press conference here in Brussels where
the spokesperson of the European
Commission also made clear that the
individual closing of national borders
is not something the Commission regards
as helpful
seeing that the virus has already spread
to all of the EU's member states and
that although as banned Rika has pointed
out there are currently no traffic jams
this is something one wants to avoid
Beaumont's the supply chains for medical
Goods and for food to remain intact
carick what is this disagreement about
border closures tell us about European
unity on this crisis the spokesperson of
the Commission made clear that this is a
mobile situation now something they
haven't seen so far so he didn't want to
say that there is this unity on that
aspect there there is movement the
interior ministers are for instance
debating now whether the closure of
external borders would be an option that
is something we heard from the office of
president macaw that within the next
couple of hours the external borders of
the European Union could be closed and
that could be an effort in order to
protect the internal market and to make
sure that the medical Goods and the food
supply remain for those people who are
and mostly need them alright DW
correspondent Gehrig mattis reporting
for us there
from Brussels thank you very much as
Germany moves to close its borders to
the rest of Europe daily life inside the
country is grinding to a halt across the
nation schools restaurants churches many
other social spaces have been closed or
restricted here's how Germans have been
dealing with the disruption an eerie
silence has descended over this Munich
secondary school just one of thousands
of schools and kindergartens across
Germany which are closed from today
until at least the middle of April in
Bavaria further drastic measures were
introduced on Monday to slow down the
spread of the virus at a press
conference which journalists could only
follow via videolink the Bavarian
premier announced a state of emergency
in his region the University Hospitals
are asking medical students to make
themselves available to assist permanent
staff retired doctors and doctors on
parental leave will be asked to come in
as well
Bavaria has also ordered the closure of
cinemas theaters and clubs restaurants
and cafes can only stay open until 3
p.m. but banks pharmacies and
supermarkets are so far exempt from
restrictions yeah seen in women kind we
don't see any reason for concern at this
time but everyone should be responsible
about what they really need and
everything will be done to ensure that
supplies are available the Robert Koch
Institute the German government's main
medical adviser said it was important to
implement tough measures now because the
number of coronavirus cases continues to
rise sharply is this an urbanist info
it's not sensible instead of going to a
club to invite people back to your homes
or to go to other parties where a lot of
people come together I'm saying this
because apparently some people have held
so-called corona parties after clubs are
closed to individual please do not do
this 200 ethnic Berlin's legendary
nightlife has also been cut back
massively clubs have closed bars that
are open are almost empty I don't have
any customers I've got a man on the door
making sure that no more than 49 people
come in then we have to close
we can't let in any more but no more
than are not coming that is the
situation now but new rules might be
announced any day even churches have
been closed for fear of spreading the
virus but that doesn't mean that those
who rely on others will be left to fend
for themselves
shop car thief's are pastors to make
sure they continue intensive contact
with people who were afraid above all
the old and the sick we will continue to
seek these people out Germany's response
to the virus is a mixture of coming
together in solidarity and battening
down the hatches and hoping that those
measures have the desired effect